you ready
voting is what 18. let me get this
straight
you mean to tell me i'm not allowed to
drink until i'm 21 years old
i am not allowed to smoke weed or
cigarettes till i'm 21 years old i'm not
allowed i'm not allowed to gamble
until i'm 21 years old but i'm allowed
to vote at 18. or you're allowed to die
for your country
and serve in the army or the military
it's absolutely pathetic to me
if you think about it yeah it's
absolutely pathetic to me when you think
about i think the voting system
needs to be changed my opinion i've been
saying this for a long time okay now i'm
not a u.s i'm not a
uh i wasn't born here i'm from iran
i came over here completely different
perspective i have
but i shot this video six years ago six
to be exact the date if you
pull it up guys we can pull up the video
date
it is april 15 2014 which is what
i look like i'm smoking weed right
legally 35 thanks skye for getting that
picture right there i'm wearing a babe
ruth
jersey but let it do you have it on 1.5
speed by the way
people are voting less than 200
presidential elections we had 61.6
percent of eligible voters show up
and in 2012 we had 58.2 percent show up
which has dropped
by roughly three percent and uh you know
the subject of voting keeps coming up
and i said we need to do an episode on
it and put some ideas together and i'll
put these ideas for a while but
i'll present it to you because look
we've had a lot of people that have
fought very hard whether it's to get
african-american with civil rights to be
able to vote or women's rights we've
come along such a
long way but uh but i think we can even
improve it even more today than before
so let me get right into it let me get
right into it
the program i'm going to be talking to
you about is called earning the right
to vote earning the right to vote the
reason why it's called earning the right
to vote i'm an immigrant
i came here from iran to america america
was willing to open the doors and allow
our family to come here and iran we
didn't have freedom of religion freedom
of assembly freedom of speech freedom of
many many things free enterprise and so
in america they offered that to us but i
didn't come and feel and entitled to all
of it i felt as an immigrant i had to
give back and earn the freedom that
america gave me so the program is called
earning the right to vote first one
point number one if you paid a thousand
dollars in income taxes the prior year
you get one vote
so what if somebody pays ten thousand
dollars in income taxes you get ten
votes what if somebody pays a hundred
thousand dollars in income taxes you
listen 100 votes
well you may say pap that's not fair the
people who pay more taxes get more votes
i simply took the system on how public
corporations or
companies who have outstanding
shareholders and outstanding shares on
the system they used and this is how it
works a company could have
one million outstanding shares but only
a hundred people
own the 101 million outstanding shares
and the way they allow to vote is not
based on
the 100 shareholders if one person owns
only one share
versus a person owns a hundred thousand
shares which one has more to say more of
a voice for this company obviously a
person that has one hundred thousand
shares and i feel
our voting system should be the same
exactly
you ought to have more of a voice on
what it is somebody who does not and if
you want to have more of a voice
you ought to pay a little bit more than
income taxes that's my id on point
number one and it would be a salary cap
with 100 shares 100 votes so you can't
go above 100 votes kind of like how
nfl has a salary cap that's the way we
put out 100 votes and the age part with
this it has nothing to do with 18 years
old 21 years old twenty five years or
thirty years old freaking every 16 year
old kid who worked at baskin robbins
last year
and he made fifteen thousand dollars and
he paid two thousand dollars in income
taxes he ought to have two votes yes you
do
wow he was completely healthy disabled
doesn't want to get it done well at
baskin robbins
i would rather hear from the 16 year old
kid who's paying income taxes and
contributing to society than a 23 year
old kid that is undecided wants to stay
home family pays for all his bills he
doesn't want to give back to society i'd
rather hear from the 16 year old
point number two of the ideas i have in
place if you serve the military whether
you pay any taxes or not you get a vote
uh but you need to complete boot camp
and ait advanced individual training i
think military is a good thing for a lot
of our younger boys to go into because
it disciplines them teaches us a lot
about
independence toughness fight freedom
honor a lot of good things i think it'll
do a lot of good things for the country
period but if somebody in the military
paid fifteen thousand dollars in taxes
he would get 15 votes because his
numbers would still
go higher but if somebody went to the
military and didn't pay any taxes you're
still getting one vote because you serve
the military point number three
public service police officers extreme
you went off the deep level
they put their lives on the line similar
to military if you're willing to put
your life on the line and go fight fires
while your wife is at home wondering
what's going to happen you got two
little ones
you want to put your life on the line
for me i mean you you have more than
earned the right to vote same with
police officers and so you get an
additional
vote if you are serving for public
service and putting your life on the
line you absolutely get the right to
vote as well
uh because of what you're doing number
four job creators nonprofit or profit
if you create a job that pays a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars
over a four-year period income so if you
hired somebody and they make forty
thousand dollars a year and they're with
you for three years you pay 120 000
you get one vote per job you created for
our economy
one vote per job you created for the
economy and the limit on that is also
100 votes you created 100 jobs you have
a hundred votes to uh uh to vote for any
kind of things that we're coming out
with point number five
retirement sales that's paid over ten
thousand dollars in life taxes they
automatically get to vote because
they've already put into economy they're
put into the
uh to the marketplace they put into our
country to contribute to society so they
get a vote no matter what the number is
ten thousand dollars
number six anyone with a four-year
degree whether you have paid into taxes
or not if you're willing to stay
disciplined
go to school get educated you ought to
get a vote and for a master's degree two
votes and for phd three votes so if you
have a bachelor's
if you have a master's and you have phd
you ought to be able to have three votes
because you have the support of
succession
more than some of the rest of us and we
want to hear from you more because you
want to put your head down and read the
books and educate yourself i think we
need more people to go out and educate
themselves like the people who stay
disciplined to get their four-year
degree
degree in their phds and obviously this
whole thing would be uh needing to have
an id to go out there and vote but we
know more times
this is how it'll look like if somebody
made 60 000 last year they pay 10 000 in
taxes
that's 10 votes if that person also has
a bachelor's degree and a master's
degree they get two additional votes if
they
serve in the military before that's an
additional vote that person could have
realistically 13 votes
to vote for an election because of how
much they've contributed to society but
this is the disclaimer idea what it has
to do with legal immigrants because
we have this whole debate with amnesty
and i've been interviewed on this one
you're about to like
this so many times people say oh they
run across the border and we need to do
this and we need to do that honestly
if i'm a father and if i'm living in a
country where i see it's not the best
thing for my kids or if i see what's
taking place in iran or mexico or any of
that stuff
and i gotta prove i'm responsible for my
kid i would go across the border to come
to america to provide a better life for
my kids wouldn't you think about that
i would too but if you look at
immigration the whole purpose of
immigration is to bring the best talent
in the world to our country we are
leading immigration
because the best talent from china from
europe from everywhere they are still
wanting to come to america it's not as
ahead of elite as we used to have at one
point right now to drop a little bit but
we bring the best talent so we have
11.7 million illegal immigrants living
in america roughly 400 000 of them were
deported last year
and out at 11.7 million of illegal
immigrants they paid a little shy of 11
billion
in taxes last year so what do we do with
the folks who are illegal immigrant
living in america this is my opinion
these are my ideas
i think if one is an illegal immigrant
but they did any one of these things we
talked about
if they went out there and they actually
paid a thousand dollars in income taxes
on the tax id number if they went out
there and actually
served the military are willing to serve
the military if they're willing to go
out and serve the military they're
willing to become cops police officers
they're qualified
they're willing to go out and create
jobs they're willing to go out there and
get a degree and get educated if they're
willing to do these things
i say we need to allow and give them the
right to go out there and
and take a quiz because they need to
need to take a test to know the history
of america with a president and certain
things that they need to know about
but i think their votes ought to count
as well uh for what they do to society
they play a very very important role
there's no reason why we should not have
illegal immigrants uh being able to vote
as well there are more people that are
illegal immigrants that are contributing
more to society than somebody would
surprise you a little bit
of society why not let them be heard as
well if they're willing to earn
the right to vote by contributing to
society so what we did is we went to the
streets and we went on a couple of
college campuses
you don't need to listen to all of them
but watch the first the second guy will
shot so many subjects such as voting and
politics and here's some of the answers
we got all right so first question is
how would you improve the current voting
system in the united states
um i was going to say maybe more parties
but i'll probably complicate things
it'll take too long probably for things
what i would do is make the vote that
the people put up when they go to the
booth and vote make that the one that
counts not the one that takes place
behind closed doors when it gets back
into the offices
in the end it's just popular really
matters shout out to mario doing the
interviews by the way different areas
encourage more people to vote i would
make it more convenient for people to
vote by decreasing the super pacs
probably better informed people by the
way he went to ucla
like people like me don't really want to
they're too lazy don't know how to even
though it's really easy prefer for there
to be
better access to voting booths as far as
politically you know you got the
republicans the
the democrats um you can pause it i
think it's playing the same you can
at this point okay by the way i hope you
don't get flagged for using the video of
uh valuetainment from six and a half
years ago these guys are not going to
come after us
so tell me about this guy's thoughts the
level of detail is staggering
staggering here's my first thought we
have poll workers who can't count to one
how are they going to count to 33 no but
there's some great points in there
um it clearly uh shows that
we just witnessed it you know things are
messed up you know i think there has to
be some sort of changes
when tick-tock can you know help decide
elections
and influence people to the level that
they do and these kids are armed with
votes
and maybe not armed with the knowledge
that they might need
something is a skew and the only way
anything would ever happen
is um the party in power found a way
that it benefited them
then they would then you know make it
happen but
how long did it take you to come up with
that formula were you working on it for
a long time oh yeah
oh yeah i've been by the way i've been
talking about that since i was 30 years
old
but i've never put in video i've been
talking if you work closely with me they
tell you
pat's crazy ideas that that i propose to
our guys for a long time i think
every single thing about a company like
to say i don't like something starbucks
does
who the hell am i to tell starbucks what
to do if i don't share the company
if i own more shares i should have more
say if i don't i shouldn't
what's the difference between that and
america but in america it's like
no even the person that doesn't own
shares of
starbucks who doesn't contribute or do
anything should have say no they
shouldn't you should have any saying it
in a household if you're not paying rent
for the house
i'm living in you got three roommates
adam you've ever had roommates
yes if you got three roommates you ever
had a roommate that never paid the bill
or never paid anything living with you
yeah do they have any say in how for you
to
bring in groceries at the table are they
paying the utilities they bring the hell
they still living with you
if they're not will you let them say
anything about how you should shift the
way you put set up your house or
apartment
good good analogy you would never let
anybody tell you what to do who the hell
are you to say anything
all i'm saying is let's pay some taxes
why don't you go pay some taxes
in the game that's all it is have some
skin in the game go pay your taxes and
they'll say what makes total sense what
about all good for me what about a
mandatory age for you where are you at
as far as voting i
i could care less about age i really
could care less about age because
to me it's not about age i know 16 year
old kids i'm being dead serious with i
know 16 year old kids more responsible
than 30 year old kids
this kid came over here from colombia
sam came here from columbia at 14 years
old
his father his father passed away he
comes to colombia
independent who's paid your bills the
last seven years who has paid your bills
last seven years
that guy should have had a vote since he
was 15 years old if he paid him two
times well according to your plan you'd
have 12.
what i'm trying to say to you is i don't
care about age i care about you
paying taxes the pain of paying taxes
you ought to have a voice democrat
republican independent i could care less
but now you have skin in the game
it's not anything well based on taxes is
what you're saying this i didn't just
say taxes you didn't see taxes okay
that's education if you get a degree you
have military
if you serve the military you have votes
if you want to be a firefighter you have
votes
it's skin in the game dude the
firefighters we sit there we see
firefighters with things just a regular
i one time got into a market i remember
this kevin pearson guy years ago if he
hears this he's going to be shell shock
i remember his name because i was like
17 years ago
and i went through the market of
firefighters for a span of six months i
worked with these firefighters and was a
bunch of these guys all studs
you know how many of them went through a
divorce every one of them had a divorce
it's a rough life
it's tough for personal life it's tough
for parenting they go through challenges
they lose friends they're burned
legs body parts coming home these are
not easy jobs everything we're talking
about bashing cops
you go talk to a wife and a son who lost
their dad on a
you know front line doing work they got
shot they got then then go ask him what
it feels like to be a cop you think that
kid wishes
that wasn't a cop that kid wishes that
had a regular job working at
staples or a different place these
people deserve the right to have so for
me it's not about just taxes
it's about earning the right to vote so
you can have say
if you're looting if you're going out
there fooling around
ruin what this great nation is all about
you should have zero say
zero vote nothing if you're not
contributing to the society
zero i'm in i mean the level of
time and effort that you did to even
come up with this
completely wild and outlandish plan is
actually incredible it gives us
some deep insight into your mind i mean
obviously
it's very complicated and we don't know
how many votes a certain person would
get is complicated i mean is it fair to
say that
that's not getting implemented anytime
soon however
i do with
amazing level of respect
the fact that you care that much to take
the to because that wasn't easy to come
up with i mean how much man hours it
took you to come up with that
that's that's what we need more of
people who care that much saying this is
what it needs to be i'm not even talking
about
left right you know center i'm just
talking about you care that much
this is what it means to be an immigrant
from iran
to do you have no voice there when you
can earn your voice go to the army
become a businessman become an
entrepreneur
you know one thing that i'm happy to see
i mean to
to that yeah we just had the highest
voter turnout since
1900 in america so whatever you want to
say about
you would not have had the highest
turnout since 1900 if we had to check
everyone's id there's no way in the
world this would have been the highest
you realize no way in the world this
would have been the highest if we all
had to see the id
zero chance that's what you think it
came down to no no no no i don't think
that's what it came down to
it's absolute math it's not maybe
it's not 99 accurate statement i'm
making this is
100 statement i'm making if we had to
check
100 of everyone's ids who voted we
wouldn't have this many votes
so how do you vote without id mail and
balance what do you mean that's just how
you don't have to have a nice no you
just dropped what do you mean you just
drop how'd you do it
i mean that had my name on the ballot
yeah but did you show your id or no i
had a mail in ballot no but so you
didn't show it so how did they know you
sent it and nobody knows somebody else
cause you're saying
you're saying have to show up there is
no way in the world listen
a decision this big a decision
you know what this would do this system
look a lot of people are saying
i'm conservative i absolutely disagree
with pat i love that
some people are saying screw the
snowflakes fine
some people are saying i'm a
conservative i partially agree with some
of them
some people are saying i 100 agree with
pat the whole point is
i don't care whether you agree or not
start the damn conversation
i don't care if you agree and you want
to break the whole thing down go do it
start the conversation there's no way
and by the way adam for yourself you
know a lot of people
would see a program like this and you
know what they would say they would say
it's so extreme
but you know what's crazy that's exactly
how they live their lives
let me say this one more time a lot of
people would see this thing here and say
it's extreme
but that is exactly how they raise their
kids
that's exactly how they live their lives
you and i just talked about somebody in
your life where you said you know they
had their kids when they were younger
right and he said
are they still married he said no
because the father wasn't working right
he wasn't a working man whatever you
said that real briefly
okay he didn't have skin in the game
what
what do you think your responsibility is
and the mother had to choose to go find
another man who was willing to work of
course
that's the skin in the game when a woman
leaves a man why does a woman leave a
man
how many times your story about a woman
leaving a man cause he can't make money
how many times you leave find out a man
leaves a woman because
he just doesn't like the way she treats
him or she takes care of the kids
everyone's gotta have a skin in the game
kids gotta have a skin in the game
family's gotta have a skin in the game
friends gotta have skin in the game do
you think you would have friends without
a skin in the game i guarantee you
wouldn't have friends with skin in the
game
if you had friends that you went to the
bar with and every i had a friend of
mine
very interesting i'm the guy that likes
to pay i like to pay
i enjoy paying whatever you want to call
it i enjoy paying i like going out i
like to pay
but if i go and i sense that somebody is
taking advantage of that
you will probably not go out with me
ever again that'll be the last time
if i get a feeling that you're just
thinking because i have money
and you want me to pay every time we're
done it's not going to happen again
we'll hang out you ain't going out with
me again because i know you're thinking
i should take the bill because i have
money i don't play that game because
everybody ought to have a skin
in the game this is not a radical idea
people live this life voting-wise scares
the [ __ ] out of them in case if we go in
this direction which that part i
understand because a lot of people lose
their votes yeah and the people who that
conceivably could be in power here very
very shortly this is the last thing
they'd want
because this worked out very well for
them how it just happened
and to think that we're not even
seriously considering uh changing
you know how this voting is going um so
how many votes
would you have in in the pbd voter
system how many votes would you have i
don't care to have a record-breaking
vote or two i'm gonna ask you
you know how many people like how many
votes would you have personally no he's
saying in your formula
i don't know yeah i have no idea how
many i'd be limited at 100 because i'd
reach my limit i wouldn't have more than
100 volts listen if i pay 50 million
dollars in taxes i'm not getting 50
million votes i'm only getting 100 votes
so there's a cap at 100. there's no
abuse so a billionaire cannot say i got
17 million votes no you don't you only
have 100 100 votes
but i would want you to max out your
votes go get 200 votes
i would encourage you to go get your 100
votes go become 100 vote person
so you can say my vote is 100 votes
have pride in it i'm 100 vote person i
voted then people will say damn
they'd have to print a lobby then we
would wreck i would recognize you in
america
i would say wear the shirt that says i
had a hundred votes people gonna say
that's that guy's a hundred club damn
adam's part of the hunter club legit dog
good for you
now the person says ten votes good for
you bro ten votes now four votes how do
you have four votes i got my ph.d
phenomenon and i got
this okay phenomenal congratulations to
you it becomes a real recognition how
many
i just voted why do you think the vote
doesn't matter to them because you
didn't earn the right to vote you just
got voted because you hated somebody
yeah it's not how voting should be
voting should be great freaking job
good for you and if people um take some
pride in voting they could also lose the
right right didn't you say by rioting
and things like that you could lose
votes
yeah again going back to it to me you
don't trust me to
drink until i'm 21. you don't trust me
to smoke weed or cigarettes until i'm
21. you don't trust me to
gamble until i'm 21 but you trust me to
vote
at 18 having never paid any taxes and i
have the right to vote
problematic we shouldn't celebrate that
record-breaking people turn out to vote
that's no celebration we should
celebrate
a record-breaking amount of people pay
taxes we should celebrate a
record-breaking amount of
people created a job we should celebrate
a record-breaking amount of people
serve the military we should celebrate a
record-breaking amount of people
went and got bachelor's degree we should
celebrate the record-breaking amount of
people that became cops and firefighters
we should celebrate service service
service
service service that's what we should
celebrate
the more we celebrate that guess how
everybody thinks at that point
service when the basic thing about how
you teach
dogs is what dog poop pees outside what
do you do
you give them a treat good job buddy
awesome job come here here's a treat
phenomenal job
dog goes and does everything you ask him
to do you give him a treat
when we become kids what do parents do
with us good job buddy you did your
chores
great job you can watch some tv you can
play some video games right
whatever we incentivize kids adults in
america they're going to do that the
rest of their lives
if you incentivize me sitting home and
collecting checks i'm going to be doing
that
if you want me to just stay home and in
california you're going to put me at a
four star hotel
you said wow four star hotel really
why would i want to be homeless you're
incentivizing that
it's pathetic that this is even have to
be explained the concept that this has
to be explained
is what's really pathetic about it yeah
the idea that this is somehow a
controversial concept
is what's pathetic about it if we got a
country
give us 10 million people give us a
country the size of i don't know give us
a land the size of texas
give us a country the size of florida
give us 20 years
look what happened to our country let me
say this one more time if we had a
country
where we set up the guidelines our
constitution our values and principles
based on the way we want to do it
give us 20 years and see what would
happen we beat a hub of innovation
around the world
we beat a hub of the best talents around
the world we would
create and solve every problem in the
world
if we had the right values and
principles that we could create not this
nonsense stuff to try to please
everybody
yeah and we're just at the beginning of
a four-year cycle of it it's uh
kind of sad let me ask you pat yeah
again
kudos shout out to the even your your
train of thought here but we talked
about 16 and 18 year olds yep you know
drinking smoking uh voting driving all
that
you know i would say 90
plus percent of high school students 16
17 18
are just in school they're not working
they're not working at baskin-robbins
the majority
right i mean obviously some kids are
working and doing like little part-time
jobs
not paying much in taxes is my point
fair point sure
okay the the the question i have
is doesn't that sort of disincentivize
them
meaning they have not paid any taxes
they're 18 years old so the next time
that they'd be able to vote
is that age 22. so now you have a you
know a
six year span four to six year span of
our youngest minds our
high school students our college
students i'm not talking about whether
they're liberal conservative
yeah that's you know five plus years of
them being completely disengaged in
politics yeah
isn't that sort of no you know what it
does what is that here's what it does
it makes it that much more special when
you get the right to vote you celebrate
that much more when it's not a handout
you celebrate the vote a father takes a
son and saying i'm so proud of my son he
earned the vote
a mother takes her daughter and her son
saying i'm so proud of my kids they
earned the right to vote today and it's
emotional
parents cry kids will cry i earned this
vote
versus here's who i'm going to vote for
because somebody in school hates
such and such i'm going to vote for the
other guy that's what i'm going to vote
for you think they vote
logically do you think 18 years are
going to vote logically you really think
18 year olds world largely no but
okay again i love your idea here but
here's another problem yeah
you're 18 you still haven't paid
anything in taxes yeah you go
go to college okay you're taking out
student loan debt you i mean your
daughter just graduated from
from college right she i assume she has
not had a job per se
so you go to college you're there for
four years you still have not paid any
taxes you've taken on debt
now you're 22. well you know what [ __ ]
it i want to get my masters i want to go
get my doctorate get it
now you're going to school for another
two more two years four years
so now you have a lot of 25 year olds
who have still
never voted didn't you get it that a
bachelor's degree gets a vote
yeah but until you're 25 you know you
know bachelor's degree takes 22.
what are you talking about so when
you're 22 you get one vote so that's
of course i don't care if you've ever
been that's millions and millions and
millions of people that
don't get to vote until they're aged 25
but if they don't
i was paying taxes at 16 years old
what age did you pay taxes first time
you ever paid taxes yeah
probably like 18. i don't know okay yeah
you earned your vote
you had a thousand dollars in taxes
that's it okay you earned
your vote i'm proud of you you earned
your vote we ought to be proud
of our 16 17 18 year old kids who earned
we ought to celebrate people
earning their vote let me say this it's
a celebration
it's a recognition it's a milestone a
man
a woman should have on the wall in my
lifetime i've had 13 000 votes in my
lifetime i've had
628 votes it's a celebration okay
last year i had 62 votes you're a
shareholder i own a piece of america
i'm proud to be american i love this
country i have skin in the game
i'm with you dude the reason i have so
many questions on this isn't because i'm
like well i think this no i know i know
you're not
because it's such a fascinating idea
it's such a fascinating school of
thought
such a fascinating way that i even think
about it that i'm asking these questions
because i'm thinking hmm
well what about this what about that
what because it's it's it's it's it's
sparking some things that are so takara
truth says yeah let's ruin democracy pat
great
go more go deeper into it tell me what
you mean by that voting should be based
on meritocracy
16 here as well raul castillo raul
calido are you paying taxes i pay taxes
at 13 years old
had a work permit to work as a minor
patrick healer i have no problem
with the age paying taxes i could care
less about the age
i care about the habits so can you vote
at age 13. i pay taxes
adam could you vote at age 13 i could
because a 13 year will understand the
pain of paying taxes
i wouldn't care if a 13 euro voted they
paid into the system
if you're 12 years old you own a share
of a company i don't care if you own a
share of the company you have say
what do you want to vote for you have
say to me you know how they say the
brain is not fully functioning until
you're 25 years old you've heard this
saying before
yeah some of them say it happens at 30
some say it's 25 years old that's why
even a rogan says he doesn't believe kit
should smoke he says you shouldn't smoke
weed until after 30.
what a point don't smoke we don't tell
you that's 30 years old
so ridiculous but it's not about so
ridiculous what he's trying to say is he
needs to start smoking weed until later
on in life he was not a smoker early on
he started later on so it's a lot he's
gone down a dirty path it's a
logical processing to say brain be
informed
but if you're 14 years old and you've
already experienced what it's like
to pay taxes you've had the pain of
being independent listen i trust you
more than a 25 year old
that's got a silver spoon in his mouth
never had a job is a schlep sleeping on
everyone friend's couch and [ __ ] and
complains about mommy and daddy
and the fact that he wants another
thousand dollars from his rich dad yeah
that guy shouldn't have a say
where does this factor into bloated
government and big government because
this ain't an easy system there's gonna
have to be
the most ridiculous in-depth system to
count the votes you did paid these taxes
and you got your doctor and you get 13
votes
but then you failed the class and the
next thing you know you got to you know
go back to school and then you only get
14 vote like
it could get it's a slippery slope here
again i commend the thought process here
it's ridiculous it's absurd to see your
brain
in action it's just there's a lot johnny
johnny just paid five bucks he says
by the way some of you guys paid 20
bucks 15 bucks 10 bucks i saw it i'm
trying to catch up to you pd's on the
roll i'm 100 and tell me
where your new test country is eric
whittlemeyer
man i want to recognize the other guys
we didn't catch you but
we will next time love the idea of
johnny van johnson
but voter fraud would be even worse if
votes weren't
correlated to population 101 i don't
think so i disagree i think it'd be a
lot easier to do that because it's data
it's data if you have the data to show
you work you have it if i can show my
tax here's how much i paid it
irs would know how much i paid in taxes
it's data it's automatic data
all of that is trackable see it's easy
to track who's a shareholder that's not
hard to do
it's easy to track who's giving their
opinions on a shareholder call because
you know who it's a document that
everybody has who's a shareholder
at the end of the year the government
could print out a system to say this
year
this is how many votes you get adam who
do you want to vote for yeah and there's
people that just say you know what i got
100 votes i've qualified but i'm not
going to vote
that's okay don't you think there's
people there's just two different types
of people in this country people that
want to be in
feel they should be incentivized to do
things that you've earned the right to
do something like
vote and everything else and everybody
else that thinks that hey it's my
privilege it's my right i can do
whatever i want i can do that
look at look at california they spend
way more time trying to figure out what
you could do in between bites of a
thanksgiving dinner
than something practical like this and
there's no way
that there's any the sad thing is
there's no way for any hope for this
because
the democrats would never want something
like this how do you count dead people
then
you know let's get all the the kids
coming in there to vote that don't even
know what they're doing
yeah no this the chance just so you guys
know i'm not pitching this to see that
this is going to be past the next couple
years the chances of this passing
the chances of this passing is more
likely in a different country than in
america
the chances of discussions they would
call you a racist for even coming up
with the i
love it i would love to debate anybody
who calls me racist i'd love i'd have
such a fun time with them if they call
me racist what country could you see
this happening
any country that wants to compete with
america because america is getting so
soft that
look here's how competition works let me
tell you how competition works
competition works the moment you notice
a nation getting arrogant
be ready the moment a nation gets
arrogant be ready
be ready it's interesting times coming
around the corner the moment you get
arrogant cocky in sports
in business what do arrogant people do
they no longer wake up at the same time
they no longer have the same fire the
urge
you know i'm interviewing a guy
yesterday he says uh oh
what's gonna make you more fired up
today because you have more money today
than before
how is that fire still gonna be i said
you don't know who i am i'm i'm more
fired up today than i've ever been in my
life and you guys both know what i'm
talking about our buddy here
i said i have more fire in my belly
today than i've ever had enough 42. i'm
more fired up today than i was at 23
years old
then i was 25 years old i'm so fired up
so it's you got 100 votes now
you know you get 100 i've had 100 votes
since i was 26 years old i've had 100
votes for a long time
my hundred votes is not a recent thing
you said you look like a million dollars
what'd i tell you
i've looked like a million dollars since
i was 27 28. this is not about
looking like it this is about knowing
and thinking like it this is logical
reasoning
you don't have to agree with it i'm not
telling you this is going to pass
i'm not telling you you know the chance
i can't even run for office i can't run
for president i can't run for it i'm not
born here
but all i'm saying is if a country took
this idea and their foundation from the
beginning is like this that's a
dangerous country
everybody would wake up saying i can't
wait to earn my vote yes and i wish you
had the choice to
go to a country like that i wish there
was something
felons get a chance to vote in your
country you're paying taxes
yeah yes you do you're a felon yes you
do you know why can a felon own a share
of apple
yeah of course of course i don't care if
you're a felon you get to vote
because you're skin in the game yeah i
don't care about
cr felons i don't care about to me it's
skin
in the game you pay taxes
you're a felon totally understand you
screwed up hey
bad for you should have never done that
but you came out you got a job you paid
three thousand dollars in taxes you have
a vote
100 color doesn't matter discrimination
doesn't matter i don't care what color
you are what nationality or what
religion you are i could care
less that's your choice atheist agnostic
christian seven-day
catholic doesn't matter heights
any of that stuff doesn't matter do your
thing you contribute you get to vote